[Music]
kamilla Kibeho is talking about Shawn
Mendes their new collab and their
relationship Camila covers the new issue
of clash magazine inside she gets candid
about Shawn revealing she's known him
the longest out of anybody in the music
industry adding quote it's actually a
really beautiful feeling to know that
this person is always going to be in my
life we're always going to love each
other yeah love well she doesn't confirm
if they're more than friends she does
say Shawn is one of the few people in
her life that she trusts completely
quote he is just normal and that is so
rare and precious to find in this
industry
she's amazing like super talented a
songwriter like I was so no I mean I've
never worked at the actual songwriter
who I clicked with as well as to her so
[Applause]
the bear has been hit with romance
rumors for years though since 2015 when
they released their first collab we
kinda just wrote it for the sake of
writing it not even I didn't even think
that it would be heard anywhere or like
be released anywhere so when his label
picked that as a single I was kind of
like okay cool but I think like I'm just
you know it's really it's a really cool
thing that happened but I don't think
you can plan those things I don't at the
time the pair both told ET nothing
romantic was going on the record
straight no we are just friends for
edges on we're not dating
yeah we're just friends he's like one of
my best friends he's amazing Camila and
Sean have been spending a ton more time
together though a source tells ET quote
Camila just got out of a relationship
and sean is on tour the duo isn't
looking to get into anything serious
right now
Camila is also hard at work on her
upcoming album I just feel really like
appreciative of being able to like live
and I feel like I just know what's
important we in in life right now so I'm
just I'm really happy and I feel very I
don't I feel like really in touch with
my emotions